كل ما تفعله لا تخبر توم كروز
بالذهاب من الجرف لأنه سيفعل
ذلك بعيدًا وبعيدًا ، وهو أخطر
شيء حاولناه على الإطلاق ، نعم أراهن أنك
تقول إن كل مهمة مستحيلة
[موسيقى]
ولكن هل سيذهب حقًا  قيادة
دراجة بخارية
[موسيقى]
من جبل ، نعم ، لقد كان دائمًا يمسك
بسدادات الأذن الخاصة بي ، لذا لا أسمع نفسي
أصرخ
صراخ معجبيه حول مدى الجنون ،
هذا هو عدد الطرق المختلفة
المتاحة للقول المقدس
بعد ركوب الدراجة من نرويجي
في نهاية المطاف ، فتح الجبل مظلته
[موسيقى]
وعلى الرغم من أنه سمّرها في أول لقطة له ،
لم يتوقف توم
هذه الأوقات اليوم ، يمكن أن يضيف Crews هذه
الحيلة الأخيرة للتعليق على طائرة
أثناء الإقلاع ،
شاهد
فيلمًا ويقف فوق طائرة ذات سطحين ولا
ننسى الركض حول السطح الخارجي
لأطول مبنى في العالم ناهيك عن
تسلق الصخور الذي كان يجب أن يكون لدى معظم الناس
صخور في رؤوسهم ،
حيث كان تام في أحدث مهمة
مستحيلة 7 قاموا ببناء منحدر خاص
للموتوكروس هو  أنا أتدرب على
13000 قفزة تدريبية ، أقول إن 500 صانعي الأفلام يمارسون القفز
بالمظلات على الأقل
لم يكسر توم كاحله كما فعل عندما
اصطدم بجدار ، لذلك هذا
من الجانب هنا نذهب ، قمنا بتصويره
بثلاث كاميرات حسنًا هنا  يذهب ويأتى بوم
ويشاهد الإعادة المؤلمة على برنامج
جراهام نورتون شو الآن
حسنًا ، لم ينته أي شخص آخر
[تصفيق]
لقد ذهب كروز من
القفز من على طاولة القهوة في ملابسه الداخلية
[موسيقى] وهو
يركب من جرف جينيموس  سي إن إن نيويورك